as you can tell by the title of this
video I'm doing a favorites video whoa
grace a Q&A and a favorites video all in
the same week don't strain yourself
this camera is wobbly bobbly here just
so you guys can see my usual tripod is
with my friend mamrie so this is the
tripod scenario that I have set up in
its place whoa
yes very tripod much MacGyver yes it's
that time of the month again that random
time where I think it seems appropriate
to do a favorites video so let's get
right into it that keep saying can't
stay out can you stay out this is orbit
dry texturizing spray
maybe I mentioned this in last video I
know I definitely mentioned dry bars
three in one spray thing but this one is
also great and it does come in a travel
size I got this gifted through a
beautiful wonderful fabulous makeup
artist Natasha who did my makeup when I
was in New York promoting the grace
Helbig show she did looks like this
missing this watch and she gave me this
spray because she does a great
relationship with this company and they
sold that she used to go in my hair for
those things and they gave it to me
little do they know I know little about
doing hair but this stuff especially
with short hair mix it a lot easier to
do your hair you spray this stuff in oh
it sounds aggressive but it smells great
it gives your hair texture now my hair
looks like a magic eye when you stand up
close you're like I had just looks and
then you back up and you're like oh yeah
yeah keeps me out you see AK you see it
I don't even know where or how I got
this
this is tarts BB cream BB tinted
treatment primer I've been using this as
primer for my foundation and it's
fantastic I really like full coverage
foundation because my skin is really
sensitive to lights and to embarrassment
so I break out in hives and redness a
lot I can't use like BB creams or CC
creams or those
things because they don't have enough
coverage for me but this one does a
great job also as a primer before using
a foundation it works really well it
keeps my foundation on my face which is
the place for it to be next yeah can you
see can you see can you see yeah this is
for my hair you perverts this is a new
me three-in-one wand everyone talks
about new me wands or curling wands in
general and I have a bunch of cheap
curling wands that I've purchased from
drugstores when I'm traveling and
realized I forgot the last one that I
purchased at a drugstore while I was
traveling because I forgot and there's a
lot of beauty gurus out there that have
deals on the new me website where you
can like type their name in with a
vanity URL and get a huge deal but I
didn't do that because I'm and um I
found these on heart look which is the
website I also really loved it's a great
one for curling the hair like do blue
blue blue it comes with this travel
package which I clearly yep it looks
like a murder package it's black and
it's leather and it comes with some
gloves the wand itself comes with all
these different barrel shapes the one
thing I wish it had that it doesn't is
it only has on/off it doesn't have a
temperature setting it also came with a
straightener I assume because it was all
in one package that the straightener
might not be that great and the
straightener is really great knack yeah
you see I see a case yeah this is an
oldie but a goodie I think I've put this
in favourites videos before maybelline
age rewind under-eye concealer it's
awesome it's got this squishy little top
which many makeup artists would say
that's not hygienic
and to that I say what did you say I
fell asleep while you were complaining
about a product that I like but it's
probably gross for your skin c'est la
vie what you do is you twist it huh and
then you pat it under your eyes and you
dab it in for me it works as a concealer
highlighter under my eyes and makes me
look like I got that REM sleep that all
the people that don't drink talk about
what's that like you guys cool next yeah
can you see I can see I can you see yeah
I'm getting water everywhere this this
is such a
terrible angle of it is a clothing
steamer it's um here I'll show you it's
a clothing steamer to steam all the
wrinkles out of your clothes I'm awful
at ironing but and I'm awful at washing
my clothes and drying them properly so
they all have wrinkles forever
and when I travel I have to use ironing
boards in hotel rooms and it's literally
like I'm doing my own private physical
Pramod a show and I don't even want to
see it and I'm the only audience member
there so I invested it in a clothing
steamer and it's the greatest thing its
so easy to steam out clothes and you go
like a TSA agent after you've set the
metal detector off you just scan it next
see you say yes yeah okay yeah culottes
what are culottes you say not the failed
snack product I tried to bring on Shark
Tank no I mean if the technical
definition is but they're like a
wide-leg capri pant I'm obsessed with
culottes these denim ones I bought at a
Zara in France when I was in can for cam
Lyon and these are just really cute and
great and comfortable might be my
favorite ones of all time about these at
H&M before I went to Hawaii because I
wanted to be that stereotypical terrible
tourist version of myself and turns out
these are cool in only my opinion you
might think otherwise this fabric I
don't know what it is it's crazy magic
fabric because it never wrinkles this
was literally sitting in my dryer for 24
hours because like I said story checks
out I'm not good at washing and drying
clothes and I just pulled them out
thinking I'd have to use my awesome
steamer to get the wrinkles out to
pretend to you guys that they weren't
wrinkled and they just weren't wrinkled
and then I just got an order from Gap
calm because I'm a monster and can't
stop buying clothes and I got these
white culottes
haven't actually tried them on might be
terrible but for now in this blissful
ignorant moment before I actually try
them on they're great next yeah you say
you say yes yeah this is the person I
from Banana Republic calm because I hate
interacting with human beings don't hate
it just not good at this time I bought
this off the website was like 40% off
I have been buying a lot of clutches
with your purses that don't have handles
so I have to hold them awkwardly so I
invested in finally a purse that has
straps so I could go like this look I
can do so much with my hands I finally
learn American Sign Language or go like
this and feel sad about never actually
learning American Sign Language okay
this has been a very long favourites but
I hope that you enjoyed it on any level
whatsoever if you did give it a thumbs
up because that's a great way for me to
measure if you made it to this part of
the video and leave a comment down below
letting me know if you also like any of
these things or if there's things you're
loving this month that I should
absolutely know about and then put in my
favorites video next month as if I
organically found it on my own also
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel if you don't like living in a
constant state of idiocy just kidding
you're great I don't know this is a new
me three-in-one wand the only threesome
I need it's right here this is the girl
holding up the most phallic dildo
looking device